like I feel like crowd work is in the
ethos right now like Matt Rife is yeah I
mean people it's so funny
Matt's great but every time someone like
becomes somebody that people notice that
does crowd work like they're like yo why
are you [__] jacking their style it's
like dude it was it used to be Andrew
Schultz and now it's Matt Rife it's like
dude everyone does crowd work when the
[__] crowd is nuts you just do it and
they're like this guy's trying to be
[__] this guy it's like dude like
everyone just does crowd work when the
[__] pops off and sometimes the ship
pops off and when it does I gotta make
sure that it [__] I can handle it and
you're doing business man because you
can find me in a place of business Tupac
said the best [__] huh extra paper scoop
that is that a Cool J but anyway
did you see that was parked I don't care
I did there's a lot cool Jack though I
just say stuff that you say oh cute dude
all right so what do you want to know so
the difference like crowd work well
crowd work is when you go into the crowd
and start asking crowd questions and
then work off the crowd through what
they say yeah I I know that part but
like it seems like magic so like what
are like okay I'm gonna tell people
right now this is what it well here's
what crowd work is yeah to me it's
flirting if you're not good at flirting
you can't do it you have to be able to
be comfortable enough with the opposite
sex or the same sex if you're into them
and confident enough to be able to crack
jokes with them if you can do that then
you can figure out how to do it on stage
uh because that's really all you're
doing is you're making fun of people in
a nice sweet joking way or you're
roasting them and which you can also do
that flirting wise too is called negging
right if you have to be good at flirting
then how are you so good at crowd work
[Music]
killed it dude you killed me see that
would be good groundwork thank you I'll
be good crowd working in the crowd so uh
uh
um
you you can't go oh to your own thing by
the way
I just did a baby
that black kid with the glasses standing
there the meme like in the sea of people
yeah yeah but they go no but they do
like this and then the one guy's like
that yeah okay cool they say librarian
ambulance but um so what what uh yeah
here's the actual uh truth though and
people I think comedians don't like
saying this because it it people are
communities were good at crowd work they
wear it as a badge and it it is
definitely hard to do and it's
definitely a different thing like some
great comedians are horrible hard work
and some people are really good crowd
work and not the best comedians but I'm
gonna tell you right now generally
across the board crowd work is way
easier way easier than material is that
the general consensus absolutely and
comedians will will either not publicly
say that or it's not like a big thing I
mean [__] comedians some communities
would say that but I feel like people
don't talk about that a lot because they
like to think their crowd work is badass
but dude it's so much harder to have
good material than it is to have good
crowd work because good passable crowd
work is
if you can't do passable crowd work you
should never be on stage because all you
have to do is literally be like hey nice
jacket hey what's going on there where'd
you get that uh [__] uh this this and
then people like oh he's making fun of
the moment what's happening right now
that's so easy but it does seem like
magic it is well because it's special
for this time yeah and it's special for
us and people think it's great when it's
your friends and then the people in the
room that are in the room with you are
being made fun of but to actual craft
and I hate using that word but to craft
a joke five minutes it's [__] I don't
even I just don't even know how
comedians do it
it's so hard to do that yeah it is hard
um you know who does great crowd work I
haven't seen them in a long time but he
always makes me [__] loud Rick Ingram
Oh yeah he's yeah he's great well he's
like one of the best at it Izzy yeah
yeah yeah
he's so good at crowding him like coming
onto the stage yeah he's especially when
he would follow you he's great whatever
he would say he would follow me all the
time
uh I don't remember now he was saying
something like I mean you're gonna have
to believe this but I just heard all the
[__] in the room drying yeah yeah
yeah yeah he would say that no no
they're leaving that that's that's kind
of nice so um so wait uh yeah he's
hilarious but he also
um but here's the other thing about
crowd work is
and I said this before but like Eminem
is amazing at rhyming right freestyling
and when you when you watch it you're
like how the [__] is he rhyming all
these words in real time but what you
don't realize is
he's already
thought of everything that has rhymed he
already knows so he's just pulling from
his database so they're so crowd work is
if you've done stand up long enough and
I've done it for 17 years if you've done
it long enough
you have situations that arise that have
been versions of things that you've been
dealing with for years so it's not like
it is still very impressive when a
person is if you crush with crowd work
that's impressive it is but
you're just picking from uh I've been
here before I'm comfortable enough oh
what's this person going to say [__] it
I know what to say because I've done
this before in [__] Wichita the same
kind of thing happened it's always a
little different but
um you get the stuff that you say and
you and you and you and you fired it off
it's kind of like material but it's not
though but I like to I like to you know
sometimes I do get into a rut I have
gotten into a rut before of saying the
same thing crowd work wise and I'm like
I gotta change that man because I'll
I'll like record it and then I'll be
like oh that's too much like this all
the time I don't want to post it so I
like try to like um
force myself to talk about different
things in crowd work which is what the
the one the half hour thing that I did
on my on my YouTube is uh is on right
now which is uh it's all it's all like
just off the cuff stuff I was in a crowd
with a bunch of gang members and [__] in
Pueblo Colorado and uh I mean that crowd
was [__] insane they were insane and
and no comedians go there and and it's
like yeah no comedians are gonna come
there if this is a [__] these are the
the people in the thing
but I was I was in the [__] one of
the reasons I did half an hour material
and then there was one dude just in the
back doing like this kind of thing and I
was like all right what what are you
saying bro I was just like dude I'm not
doing this for you guys didn't some guy
get stabbed outside of your show in uh
Oakland wow yep I have another comedy
question okay so this is something I
thought a lot about but I've never asked
you really yeah I don't know I I just we
spent a lot of time together sweetie I
know but we talk about other stuff that
we never really talk about comments
uh
uh so like typically Comics will do
their hour and like perfect it for a
couple of years at least you're closer
to like a year yeah yeah but you know
when you first tell a joke on stage and
you get that like yeah that laugh of
like first doing it there's something to
that and then doing it over and over and
over again do you lose the magic of it
and how do you keep the Magic in a joke
that you've told a thousand times it's
hard uh sometimes because but sometimes
if I think a joke is really funny I get
excited to tell it most of the time
you know what I'm saying okay like uh
if I especially if I know it's gonna it
pushes some of the audience members to
laugh or get or not not get offended but
like you know I mean I'm not here to
offend anybody I'm here to just but so
like I'll do the joke and I'm excited to
see how this audience will react to it
so there's that which you can still be
excited about it but often you'll do a
joke
like I told this one I did a new bit a
[__] a month ago I gotta
gotta do it in Vegas now coming up but
um but I heard it four or five new
minutes no and um
and uh it crushed and the second time
you do it it'll bomb
it's just I don't know because because I
think that that's the most time you're
trying to you're not speaking from your
truth you're trying to recreate what you
did oh and so you need to get past that
and then try and
um
just uh
try and just uh find the excitement in
but I I'm I I'm I think I'm particularly
like it's it's I'm I think I'm good at
that like I like to find the excitement
because it's exciting for me I think
it's hilarious that I'm even doing stand
up like all the time so like when I'm on
stage I'm so happy
and uh you know I used to like try to
not laugh because I was having fun I was
like I shouldn't laugh but then I was
like why am I trying to not I was like
I'm having so much fun [__] I'm gonna
laugh and then like people will be like
I like your laugh so I'm like all right
[__] I'll just do it
you know
um but yeah it it can it can you can
lose like sometimes I'm like I'm sick of
this joke like I toured Man on Fire for
two years and I was like dude
I have to film this like this I'm so I
should have filmed this six months ago
and now I'm like I didn't want to do it
um with this one I filmed it in eight
months it was very quick so I think it
was right there well this new one that I
did is the best thing that I've done but
like I'm so excited for it to come out
but that was fun but right now like also
when I have it in the can when it's done
I know it's filmed I want to do new [__]
so like I'm just getting so bored of
doing it and I'm so excited what's next
you know me too yeah we don't say me too
anymore say same but um
same yeah Army also crazy
[Music]
crazy congratulations